hey everyone my name is Eddie seagull
I'm the CTO at fractional AI uh and
today I'm here to talk to you about AI
voice agents and uh all the challenges
we've run into building with them and
ways we've been able to work around
those challenges so to start uh voice
models are just generally tough to
Wrangle I mean ability with llms is
tough to begin with right they
hallucinate they're defitely difficult
to evaluate coming up with metrics know
how well your system works is really
challenging especially if you're dealing
with something that is conversational in
nature where there's no objective metric
to know how well you did or how poorly
you did in a particular interaction and
latency is challenging for many
different kinds of applications that
leverage llms they're especially uh it's
an especially important challenge when
you're dealing with conversational uis
that are meant to be uh sort fluid the
way a human conversation would be fluid
and when we're dealing with audio uh and
these voice agents everything's on hard
mode you deal with all these existing uh
AI problems plus you're trying to deal
with things like transcription which is
not as straightforward as you might
think you're dealing with a streaming
environment instead of this sort of
batched back and forth uh uh kind of
interaction that you get with text and
this all makes it really really hard to
do
development so let's go into a case
study with an actual application that we
built recently so that we can see in
practice why the the sort of theory uh
was not exactly what we encountered in
practice um so for this case study we're
we're talking about uh automating this
sort of Consulting sty style of of
interview and what I mean by that is
like going into big companies and
interviewing employees there to learn
information not not interview as in a
job interview but interview as in let me
go uh into some Fortune 500 company and
understand how people are doing their
jobs this is a thing that Consultants do
all the time when they're trying to
research how something works within a
company they have to go in and do this
sort of in-depth qualitative research
where they're going a meeting with
employees at a company and asking them
questions it's a pretty expensive
process uh you know if I want to send a
bunch of Consultants into Coca-Cola to
ask employees about things they're doing
the Consultants have to spend a whole
bunch of time it's very inefficient you
got people's schedules to line up and do
the sort of you know how how do you crme
a calendar full these interviews back to
back lots of overhead but it's necessary
this is a kind of a difficult thing to
automate right you might think why not
just send them uh you know a form to
fill out or something and there's
certain cases where you probably can but
in a lot of cases you need the human
touch right you need the interviewer to
be navigating you know when do I sort of
improvise how do I build trust what
follow-up questions do I want to ask um
and also people being interviewed answer
differently when they're asked to type
out uh questions to specif or answers to
specific questions whereas like if
they're given the freedom to just ramble
they often say more stuff and so the
goal here is let's build an AI interview
agent that can replace this function
here where our AI system should conduct
interviews just like a human would
conduct these interviews should feel
less like filling out a form and more
like having a conversation but our
system will be able to interview
hundreds of people at once and not deal
with this sort of scheduling issue and
the high cost of sending Consultants
into a company um and one nice outcome
of the system should be that we get
automatic transcription of what happened
during the conversation so that later on
we can extract whatever data we need to
extract uh and aggregate it across all
these different
interviews uh so let me just dive into a
quick demo and show you what we ended up
building so you can see what it looks
like in
practice so here I just set up a test
interview that's going to ask me just a
few basic questions like you know who I
am and what I'm here to do but on the
back end this can be configured with all
sorts of different sort of use cases
that we'd have in
mind hello let's begin what is your name
and Ro in your
organization hi I'm Eddie seagull I'm
the CTO at fractional
AI pleasure to meet you Eddie as we
continue I'm curious to know what you
hope to accomplish with this interview
what are your main goals mainly I just
want to show a quick demo of what your
capabilities are so that I can talk
about what it took to build
you got it you'd like to Showcase a demo
of what I can do and discuss what went
into creating me that's a clear goal
shall we move on to another question or
is there anything else you'd like to
add no I think that's all I got for my
end thanks
thank you for taking the time to talk to
me Eddie it was great hearing about your
role and your intentions to Showcase a
demo of my
capabilities I'm looking forward to
being a part of your
demonstration so now you see what the
final product looks like we can talk a
little bit about how we started building
something like this and when we first
started we figured there's this great
open AI real time API that lets you
build uh uh you know voice agents like
this um and we just did the naive
starting thing we integrated with the
openai API we built a big prompt that
explains you know you're trying to
conduct this kind of interview and it
tells them all these things about the
interview and then puts all the
interview questions we might want to ask
into the prompt and tries to explain how
to navigate asking those
questions um the problem is like we
quickly realized that we wanted some
additional functionality here and the
one of the early things we realized we
wanted was we wanted to show a little
road map on the side of the screen that
that shows the list of questions you're
going to be asked which one's being
asked right now and ideally would let
you click on this and jump around from
question to question um and this really
just was not well suited to the
monolithic prompt approach that we had
at the beginning because there's really
no way to know what question the LM is
currently asking and it's difficult to
sort of coax it into moving around and
asking a different question if they do
click around so something we introduced
here was let's just ask one question at
a time put that one question into the
prompt that we're sending to the llm um
and then introduce some tool use here
where we give the llm access to a tool
where he can say I want to move on to
the next question now and when it says
it wants to move over onto the next
question then we'll feed it the next
tool s determin sorry the next question
deterministically and then we also added
some additional prompts that we inject
into the stream with the llm in the case
when the user just clicked around in
this road map so that the LM can be made
aware uh the user is you know we're
moving on to this question because the
user clicked next or because the user
skipped around and so this is what it
ends up looking like on our back end we
have different prompts for what happens
when a user's revisiting a question
what's happening when a user is skipping
to something new uh and this enables
some really cool behavior when we skip
around the uh the agent can now do
things like saying sure let's move on to
you know XYZ we can come back to that
later or let's go revisit that question
we were talking about about
ABC very quickly once we started playing
with this and actually using and
practice over and over again we found
that the llm had a real tendency to to
go down these rabbit holes where you
know now that we gave it this tool to
use to say I want to move on to the next
question it was hard to get it to call
that tool the appropriate amount of time
llms just loved chitchatting and asking
follow-up questions and digging down
rabbit holes and being very encouraging
about things that they hear uh and so
this resulted in sort of a reluctance to
move on to the next question uh and if
we forced it too hard then we would
eliminate its ability to improvise at
all which is obviously not what we want
so we introduced at this point an
additional background agent that's
listening to the conversation and
running a separate side thread to decide
with a totally separate call to a te
nonvoice text based llm based on the
transcript right now do we think we're
kind of like off track or on track and
we call this the drift detector agent
and so this is like a totally separate
prompt and it's just looking through the
history and it's trying to decide how
are we doing are we on topic are we off
topic is it has the question question
we're trying to ask been answered and is
it time to move on and when we get back
a result that says pretty strongly it's
time to move on we can prevent this sort
of rabbit ho holding from continuing any
further by like forcing the tool use and
you know flipping the flag on the API
call to open AI to say okay you have to
use this tool now and have to move on to
the next
question broadly it's pretty hard to get
these humanlike interviews tuned into
the right place they are always either
like following up too little or
following up too much
you want them to be able to rephrase
questions but sometimes they rephrase
them in ways that are not conducive to
the overall interview and because of our
approach of uh you know giving it one
question at a time it doesn't always
know what the whole interview is going
to be like um and also this linear flow
the only thing I can do is decide to go
on to the next question is pretty
restrictive it's either digging in
really hard into the question it's on or
it's saying okay give me what's next um
and this sort of limited the the natural
flow of the conversation
and so we introduced some things to try
and correct for this even further um the
first is we added goals and priorities
as a first class concept uh in the sort
of plan for the interview so rather than
just telling the llm here's this the
question you're asking right now we're
telling it the why behind the question
so that it can be informed when it's
trying to rephrase or informed when it's
like trying to decide how to ask
followup questions um and then we
introduce yet another side agent uh
which we call our next question agent
and this guy is just in charge of
figuring out what should we ask next and
so the first point is the this is what
the goals look like this is a screenshot
from our admin interface but you know we
have this question that it's that it's
going to ask and in this case the
question is what are your main
responsibilities in daily tasks and
without the goals you know it it may
repeat this question verbatim it'll
probably rephrase it ever so slightly
but it's going to ask something pretty
similar and then when it comes to
digging into follow-up questions who
knows like if it's going to be satis
ified after your answer like okay I
understand this person's
responsibilities and tasks are not
sometimes it's going to be satisfied
sometimes it won't so instead we add in
these goals and we say there's a high
priority goal of we want to get a clear
picture of this person's regular
activities and a medium priority goal of
we'd like to be able to start to sus out
where AI might be useful this is an
imaginary use case where you um the
reason you're doing these interviews is
you're trying to find ways to help with
AI and so this really can like help
guide what the follow-up questions will
look like and then we have this the
tuning of this side uh you know next
question bot that's just running on the
transcript in the background uh as the
conversation's going and it's sort of
taught how to be a good interviewer and
is this interviewer on track and it has
the ability to say no like it's time to
go go down this path now um uh and and
guide the rest of the
conversation um speaking of transcripts
you know these these background Bots are
running off of the transcript of the
conversation and and you also see the
transcript live when you're being
interviewed you don't just see what the
model is asking you you see what you
said to the model and luckily open AI
makes this really easy when you make API
calls you get back you know what what
did the user actually say you get a
transcript kind of you know baked into
the API response but uh a challenge in
the implementation here is that uh the
open AI realtime API it has its core
model that's listening and understanding
you but it uses a side model called
whisper that's doing the transcription
of what the user said that core model is
this fully integrated model that's able
to think about what it's hearing it's
operating in the sound domain it if you
clap or if you cough or if you bang on
the table and you ask it what you just
did it'll be able to tell you whisper
does not work that way whisper is
converting everything into text and so
uh you know if you clap you might get
some surprising results and so like this
is the result of me just not speaking I
just send some silence for a little a
while and despite the long conversation
history and all the evidence that I was
speaking English it decided I guess he's
not speaking English anymore um or
another one where there's like a little
bit of background noise and I didn't say
anything uh this is the transcript that
came out so like clearly I was not
saying creeping Dippity Dippity Dippity
Dippity but you know it said that I was
and this is not a great user experience
and there's no way to tune this there's
no uh you know if we were working with
um whisper at a low level there might be
things we can do here open AI realtime
API does not give you knobs to really
control this and so to handle this at
the ux level we added an entire separate
agent that is taking in the whole
context of the conversation as it's
happened so far here's the entirety of
the transcript and uh it's its entire
task is should we hide this piece of the
transcript from the user do we think
we'd have a transcription error um and
we still capture the transcript in that
case but now we can at least hide you
know these embarrassing examples so that
it just doesn't show up as anything to
the user and the nice thing about that
is if these these blocks are hidden the
core model still knows what's going on
so I don't include in these screenshots
what the response was but typically the
response was like you know I didn't
really get that what you know and sort
of re reass the question what what do
you hope to accomplish with this
interview I didn't hear what you said
before and so hiding the transcript
actually helps a lot in these cases for
the user
experience so as you can tell this is
getting kind of comp complex like we're
just adding lots and lots of agents to
sort of Band-Aid over different things
we're doing a test interview and seeing
how it went and realizing that we've got
these issues and then trying to uh you
know peac meal uh uh fix them in this
kind of Vibes driven way which is not
the worst thing for the very beginning
of the development cycle but this thing
is starting to get complex and now we
have a lot of different prompts to
update we have all these side agents
when we have an issue it's not clear
which one to update or if it even worked
and sometimes you're going to introduce
aggressions right you perform poorly in
one interview setting and so you update
your you know uh um your drift detector
to sort of handle that case and maybe
you just made yourself worse at the last
thing you've tried to fix with that
drift detector um this is a very
challenging situation it's common to all
llm based development but it's extra
hard in this domain we want to know how
well it's working and the answer is eval
we need some systematic way to sort of
measure uh the performance of this
system and so we ended up coming up with
in this case was a set of metrics that
that measure all the different
attributes we wanted uh to to see um and
each one of these metrics you're looking
at is you know something an automated
test Suite that we're able to run over a
conversation and then we ask an llm as
judge to measure how clear was this
conversation how complete was this
conversation how professional was the
agent um all of these different things
we see here and behind each one of these
is a a prompt that we've tuned to try
and do this evaluation
um this is really really useful for
getting uh more objective it's still not
completely objective you know we don't
have a perfect ground truth to measure
against here um there's always
Improvement that we can make in the
prompts that are measuring these things
but this is really useful for getting
further outside of this sort of purely
Vibes driven style of of iteration and
more sort of metrics driven style of
iteration um as I mentioned there's no
good ground truth here when you're
designing eval for uh you know any
system that is going to do sort of uh
you know the sorts of things you'd want
to use AI to do your ideal situation is
you've got some objective metrics you've
got some historical data to run uh your
metrics and your current system against
and you can know objectively like how
well are you doing that clearly doesn't
exist here there's no way to
say with perfect uh understanding how
well does my system work but still we
want to make sure that like we don't
ship a system that we think is okay and
then find out from users and practice
you know we have a bunch of these
interview agents go out into Coca-Cola
and we find out from Coca-Cola we're
annoying all their users for some reason
or we've got this horrible Edge case uh
so as we thought about this problem um
what we ended up introducing was
synthetic conversations where we would
come up with we would use llms to fake
users and to do fake interviews as the
interviewee and we'd run a whole bunch
of these and at least be able to measure
uh how well we think we would do against
the types of users we want to be able to
interview this also just helps with
automation so it's not us just clicking
around a bunch and taking these
interviews it gets very tiring to talk
to your computer to to test this thing
out um and so the way these synthetic
conversations work is we can just create
a Persona that Persona is used as a
prompt to the llm where we tell it who
it is you know in this case I said
you're a snarky teenager that's in
charge of a Fortune 500 company in
practice we come up with a whole list of
the types of people we expect to be
interviewing and their different
personalities their different job
functions uh and we have a whole roster
of them and then for each one we can run
it uh where the the agent interviews it
and then it uses that Persona to try and
answer the questions um and then
afterward we can run that very same eval
Suite over them and now we can get
average metrics over a broad population
of the types of people we'd be uh we'd
be
interviewing so to wrap it up you know
that was a case study with us building
with voice but I think it highlights in
general
that this approach of uh you know maybe
we just call open AI it's got these nice
voice capabilities now we'll have a nice
robust voice app is kind of wishful
thinking um you know the basic kind of
call the API do some prompt engineering
and get it into a good place is very
helpful it gets you a very uh uh gets
you very far in the development process
but it's not enough to build your robust
app as you're trying to build that more
robust app some really helpful additions
are adding some outof band checks where
you've got SE separate agents operating
in the text domain instead of the audio
domain trying to make decisions about
whether the thing you're trying to do is
is working properly um trying to get the
the overall thing back on track and Tool
use can be very um powerful for
constraining behavior and for getting uh
sort of uh as a sort of a hack to
instrument the llm and understand what's
going on instead of letting it just sort
of do whatever it wants it's got to call
your tools in order to do what it wants
and so now your tools know what's
happening um and then lastly as with all
llm based projects evals are critical to
measure success uh they're also critical
to guide development it's it's hard to
know what to do without some Metric and
even in this domain where you've got no
objective source of Truth there are
still ways to harness evals uh to get a
really robust development process